mehr am freitag um die kuh oder lage mit
blick auf den kommenden sommer den
laufenden sommer kann man sagen
und er inhaltlich starten hier auf dem
podium lassen sie mich noch kurz zwei
sätze zu uns zur institution sagen
nachdem wir heute einen livestream haben
uns vielleicht nicht alle kennen die
bundespressekonferenz eine
selbstorganisation von journalistinnen
und journalisten die über die
bundespolitik berichten und hier
pressekonferenzen veranstalten und für
mitglieder und auch die mitglieder des
vereins der ausländischen presse können
hier fragen stellen wir begrenzen die
pressekonferenz auf eine stunde und
halten es mitunter frage regel eine
frage eine nachfrage und ich nehme sie
wenn es die zeit zulässt gerne wieder
mit auf die liste so viel der vorrede
und ich übergehe waren minister
lauterbach vielen dank frau wolff vielen
dank für die einladung auch wieder das
sieht man dass wir hier werte von tagen
dürfen
ich möchte auf zwei bereiche zu sprechen
kommen zum einen wir haben jetzt eine
sommer welle vor uns und wie wir damit
umgehen können zum zweiten will ich auch
über die vorbereitung und für den herbst
ausführen so dass wir uns damit
beschäftigen können die sind wir jetzt
vorbereitet kurzfristig und wir sind wir
werden im herbst vorbereitet sein
zunächst einmal die sommer welle haben
wir prognostiziert ich bin selbst auch
von der sommer welle nicht überrascht
worden war wir gesehen hat und das in
südafrika die derzeit in deutschland
bedeutung gewinnende variante b a 5 a 4
sich auch bei hohen temperaturen stark
ausbreitet das heißt wir haben hier
nicht den sonst zu erwartenden
sommerlichen temperaturen effekt auf die
ausbreitungsgefahr warten nicht in dem
umfang zumindest müssen daher davon
ausgehen dass wir in dieser sommer welle
auch relativ hohe in studenzen haben
können auf der anderen seite ist es so
dass wir hier mehrere faktoren haben die
grund dafür sind dass man nicht hier in
panik geraten muss sondern diese sommer
welle es war ernst nehmen muss aber wir
sind nicht also existenziell gefährdet
es gibt besteht keine also
notwendigkeit hier in panik zu geraten
oder es kein alarm notwendig zum anderen
ist es eine mikron variant oder sie
verläuft harmloser besser als sie also
wohl varianten vom tätertyp zum zweiten
sehr viele bürger sind bereits geimpft
und stadt gab der impfung ist der
verlauf erneut harmloser als wenn man
ungeimpft wäre die impflücken sind
langsam schließen sich langsam und zum
dritten wir haben mittlerweile auch
einen großen teil von genesenen und
insbesondere diejenigen die chinesen
sind von der ba2 variante sind
wahrscheinlich gegen die b a 5 variante
zumindest was den verlauf angeht relativ
gut geschützt das gilt für die baa1
variante ein geschenkter aber für die
baa2 variante die aber in deutschland
eine große rolle gespielt hat in der
ablaufenden ba2 welle die durch pa 5
ersetzt wird sind also viele infiziert
worden die jetzt mit pa 50
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr infizieren
werden oder wenn dann einen harmloseren
verlauf erwarten können trotzdem es ist
nicht so dass wir die sommer welle
begrüßen können es ist nicht so dass wir
sagen können na ja gut wenn man sich
jetzt infiziert das ist vielleicht als
schutz für den herbst oder das ist etwas
was zu sehen ist wie eine impfung die
man gratis bekommt sondern auch
diejenigen die jetzt schon mit der bav
erkranken haben ein risiko schwer zu
erkranken wir haben je nach tag zwischen
50 und 130 todes fällt das ist keine
kleinigkeit das ja nach wie vor eine
deutliche über sterblichkeit
insbesondere in der altersgruppe der
über 60-jährigen kurve bedingt damit
können wir nicht zufrieden sein zum
zweiten dass longo fit risiko ist bei
der omicron variante zwar niedriger als
bei der data variante weil aber die
intention so hoch sind haben wir derzeit
sehr viele longo riet ferner dinge neu
bekommen es im cockpit risiko ist
wahrscheinlich bei der omicron variante
um etwa 25 prozent bis 50 prozent
niedriger als bei den delta war
die 50 prozent reduktion bezieht sich
auf diejenigen die zusätzlich auch
geimpft sind aber eine reduktion des
risikos ausland zu bekommen um 25 bis 50
prozent ist natürlich dann auch nicht
genug wenn man beachtet wie viele
infektionen wie derzeit haben das heißt
wenn ich fünf bis zehnmal so viele
infektionen habe wie ich früher bei der
delta variante hatte habe ich dann
trotzdem noch deutlich mehr lankowitz
fälle aus früheren daher ist das
absolute risiko für die bevölkerung
laufen fit zu bekommen derzeit relativ
hoch muss man sagen dass einer der
gründe weshalb diesem sommer werde nicht
begrüßen können und darüber hinaus
infiziert natürlich jeder der sich
infiziert hat auch möglicherweise andere
und trägt damit zu damit dazu bei dass
die wähler sich ausbreitet wir haben
jetzt auch wieder anstiege der fälle in
den pflegeeinrichtungen auch das muss
uns sorge bereiten somit ist es nicht so
dass wir also sorglos und also ohne
gegenmassnahmen dieser sommer welle
begegnen können was ich empfehle ist auf
jeden fall dass derjenige der sich
selbst oder andere schützen möchte dass
er freiwillig in den innenräumen maske
prägt das lasten tragen in den
innenräumen ist eine möglichkeit wie man
sich selbst und andere schützt da ich
bitte diejenigen die sich selbst
schützen wollen oder andere schützen
möchten dass die maske in den
innenräumen tagen das freiwillige masken
tragen muss zur normalität gehören in
unseren innenräumen das kann jeder
sollte jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
können die also daten geben dass zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt mich her dass man das
verpflichtend machen kann aber wenn man
sich und andere schützen möchte dann
sollte man die maske tragen und das ist
also eine bitte die ich an die
bevölkerung habe dass man sich selbst
und andere hier schützt und sich damit
selbst auch einen gefallen tut ich habe
auf das longboard risiken schon
hingewiesen zum zweiten aus meiner sicht
sollten wir auch großzügig umgehen mit
der indikation für die vierte im vorjahr
der sagt die situation dass bei den über
60-jährigen 80 noch nicht die vierte
impfung haben dass er selbst vor den
gruppen boten studienlage sehr klar ist
dass eine vierte und um dort schutz vor
infektionen zwar nicht perfekt aber doch
auch vor infektionen führen monate und
fast immer von schwerem verlauf
wird die vierte impfung nicht genug
genutzt daher also empfehle ich die
vierte in fünf jahren diejenigen die zum
einen durch die stiko empfehlung
abgedeckt sind die über 70-jährigen und
diejenigen die klar erkrankungen haben
ich würde es aber selbst auch großzügige
handhaben ich bin zum beispiel selbst
auch ein viertes mal geimpft weil ich
habe viele kontakte
ich möchte einfach andere nicht
gefährden durch eine infektion so wie
sie verhindern kann und möchte auch
selbst wenn ich erkrankt so leicht wie
möglich erkranken um schnell wieder im
einsatz sein zu können oder um zum
beispiel mal ein persönliches wort
risiko zu senken daher also ist man
meine empfehlung dass man also die
vierte impfung hier für sich selbst
erwägt die frage ob man ein viertes mal
geimpft wird oder nicht das ist immer
eine entscheidung zwischen arzt und
patient die stiko empfehlungen sind
empfehlungen aus der perspektive des
einzelnen also auf der grundlage einer
kosten nutzen relation die gemacht wird
und sicherheitsbedingungen aber
eigentlich konkrete entscheidung muss
immer der einzelne treffen in
einvernehmen mit sagen im arzt ich kenne
sehr viele dazu die sich selbst wo sie
noch keine 70 jahre alt sind sie selbst
geimpft haben und auch andere impfen um
eben das von kurven risiko zu senken das
risiko schwerer verläufe zu senken und
auch derjenige der es im sommer etwas
beschwerdefreiheit durch den sommer
gehen will und viele kontakte vor sich
hat dabei aber das risiko minimieren
will dass er sich selbst infiziert oder
andere infiziert der sollte ebenfalls
die wirte impfung hier erwägen ich komme
jetzt zu den
maßnahmen die wir für den herbst planen
das sind insgesamt sieben maßnahmen das
ziel ist ganz klar dass wir besser in
den herbst hinein gehen wollen als wir
das im letzten jahr konnten und auch im
jahr davor die voraussetzungen sind auch
günstigere von daher denke ich werden
wir nochmal einen herbst haben wo wir
nicht zur normalität zurückkommen aber
wir werden auch nicht so ein geschenk
sein wie wir eingeschenkt waren und
diesen sieben punkte plan möchte ich
jetzt hier kurz vorstellen der erste
punkt ist wir werden eine impfkampagne
vorbereiten wir sind jetzt aus dem engen
austausch mit den
unternehmen die angepasste impfstoffe
für den herbst entwickeln das sind
insbesondere die firmen biontech aber
auch moderner wir sind mit beiden firmen
auch also in vertragsverhandlungen so
etwas wie angepasste impfstoffe bekommen
werden die impfstoffe werden sich in der
art und weise wie sie wirken
voraussichtlich unterscheiden so dass
wir im herbst drei unterschiedliche
impfstoffe anbieten können die
klassischen uhren impfstoffe dann den
angepassten bei und dämmstoffen und den
angepassten moderner impfstoffdosis
wovon ich ausgehe dass wir diese
impfstoffe ab dem september vorhalten
können und dass wir dann jedem eine
impfempfehlung geben können und wir
werden in der lage sein werden die
impfstoffe sich in der wirkung
unterscheiden werden wir in der lage
sein jedem auf den besten impfstoff
anzubieten das aus den impfstoff wo auf
der dann vorliegenden grundlage der
studien die empfehlungen am besten
fundiert ist das werden wir begleiten
durch eine impfkampagne wo wir
insbesondere versuchen werden die
impflücken zu schließen wir werden nicht
erneut einen versuch machen die
allgemeine impfpflicht anzuführen davon
werden wir abstand nehmen wir werden
aber an ins kampagne machen wo die
impflücken gezielt angehen mit den drei
impfstoff linien die wir zur verfügung
haben zum zweiten wir werden an test
konzept also vorgelegt haben an dem wir
derzeit arbeiten ich bin derzeit in
verhandlung für die weitere finanzierung
und für die also nutzung der bürger
tätig zu werden eine empfehlung machen
wie die da geht es genauso vertragen
sind denn wer die bürger des bekommen
soll wie wir auch die qualitätssicherung
bei dem bürger tests verbessern können
und wie wir sicherstellen können dass
bei den bürger test nicht zu missbrauch
kommt dieses konzept werden wir in den
nächsten tagen vorstellen können die
bürger tests laufen die haben
dreißigsten juno aus ich gehe aber davon
aus dass wir die burgart es im sommer
weiter nutzen können und dass wir dafür
entsprechendes konzept ihnen kurze
vorstellen können zum dritten wir haben
derzeit deutliche defizite und wollen
diese defizite im herbst nicht weiter
ertragen bei der nutzung der
arzneimittel die belegter weise wirken
hier ist insbesondere taxi zu nennen
aber auch andere wirkstoffe könnte ich
hier vortragen das sind wirkstoffe die
wir haben wir bekommen gekauft die
linken vor sie werden aber bei den ideal
geeigneten patienten viel zu wenig
genutzt zum teil wird die gefahr von
omikron für ältere menschen unterschätzt
so dass so viele ersten und ersten
glauben dass diese medikamente gar nicht
eingesetzt werden müssen weil auch nikon
nicht so schwer verlief das das also
medizinisch sinnvoll wäre zum zweiten
wissen auch viele nicht wie kommt man an
die also medikamente heran ich kann man
die verschreiben wie kann man
sicherstellen dass diese medikamente
also auch dann in der zeit genommen
werden viele kennt sich auch nicht genau
aus an welchen tagen die diese
medikamente noch wirken da wollen wir
ein konzept machen was den schnellen
einsatz dieser arzneimittel die die
sterblichkeit bei den bereits
infizierten und also risiko tragen denn
patienten um bis zu 70 prozent senken
kann aus dieser medikamente eingesetzt
werden da ich habe den also expertenrat
der bundesregierung zu profit fragen
gebeten dafür ein konzept vorzubereiten
was ist im arbeit und wir werden ein
umsetzungskonzept oder und vortrag und
wo auch der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst die apotheken und die
vertrags zu eine rolle spielen werden
soweit der dritte punkt der vierte punkt
wir werden uns sehr viel präziser mit
den wohnraum gruppen und deren schutz
beschäftigen ich hatte eben schon darauf
hingewiesen wir sehen jetzt erneut
ausbrüche in pflegeeinrichtungen
wir müssen bei den pflegeeinrichtungen
eine klare auch persönliche
zuständigkeit also abfordern die zum
einen also zuständig ist für die hygiene
konzepte in den einrichtungen also
hygiene konzepte müssen umgesetzt werden
dafür muss es eine persönliche also
verantwortlichkeit einer examinierten
kraft auch in den einrichtungen geben
zum zweiten es muss jemanden geben der
zu dafür zuständig ist zum monitor ihren
dass die also bewohner entsprechend
geimpft sind entlang der empfehlungen
der stiko und entlang der also
impfstoffe der angepassten impfstoffe
die wir dann zur verfügung haben und zum
dritten wir brauchen auch jemanden der
in diesen einrichtungen dafür zuständig
ist dass die arzneimittel die ich eben
erwähnt habe mit denen man gerade in den
also wohl mehr abel und gruppen
besonders gut die sterblichkeit senken
kann dass diese arzneimittel zügig in
der zeit nach einer infektion noch
eingesetzt werden können um ihre volle
wirkung zu tätigen wenn wir das machen
wirklich gute hygiene konzepte daneben
also eine schließung der impflücken im
rahmen der vierten impfung für die also
und auch der angepassten impfstoffe für
die bewohner der wohlhabenden
einrichtungen und eben eine
beschleunigte nutzung der arzneimittel
können wir hier sehr viel erreichen dass
wir über fertigung der fünfte punkt ich
möchte erreichen dass also zum september
wird tagesaktuell
elektronisch die freien und die belegten
betten auf den intensivstationen und auf
den peripheren stationen zur verfügung
haben kann nicht sein dass wir erneut
diese information handys mit großer
verzögerung bekommen sondern zur
präzisen pandemie kontrolle brauchen wir
hier eine
aktuelle informationen in bezug auf die
frage wer ist mit kopitz schon in diesen
abteilungen in verhandlungen wie viele
hätten die personell ausgestattet sind
haben wir noch so zur verfügung und
dafür möchte ich auch der sogenannte dem
ist system setzen was ist ja
federführend vom robert-koch-institut
verwaltet und auch mit aufgebaut wurde
sodass also diese daten dann den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienste auf den
länder ebenen zur verfügung stehen aber
auf dem robert koch-institut sodass wir
tagesaktuell mit diesen daten also
arbeiten können und die pannen die
besser steuern können aus dem vorjahr
der sechste punkt wir wollen also in den
schulen und den kitas
möglichst einheitlich also hier der
pandemie begegnen dabei ist das oberste
ziel das schul und kita schließungen mit
allen mitteln vermieden werden müssen da
werden wir seitens des
robert-koch-institutes während wir mit
im test und hygiene konzepten die
bundesländer unterstützen das sei aber
darauf hingewiesen dass ist
zuständigkeit der bundesländer und die
bundesländer wollen das auch selbst
machen also es ist nicht so als wenn wir
also das nicht machen wollten sondern
dass es eine klare zuständigkeit der
länder und die länder haben uns
gegenüber auch zum ausdruck gebracht
dass sie für die hygiene konzepte und
für die also
für die also konzepte der also im
kontakt reduktion und die konstanz
konzepte beispielsweise masken tragen
oder auch eben konzepte der umsetzung
dass sie dafür selbst die verantwortung
übernehmen wollen das respektieren wir
auch wir unterstützen aber mit allen
kräften seitens das robert koch institut
ist es muss aber klar sein dass diese
arbeit dann auch geleistet ist wir
werden da auch regelmäßig die
lieferanten aber es musste diesmal
besser vorbereitet sein als in der
vergangenheit und es muss insbesondere
klar sein dass kita und
schulschließungen ausgaben und
schließlich der siebte punkt also
infektionsschutzgesetz muss also
informiert werden es läuft zum 23
september aus ich bin derzeit mit die
justizminister buschmann im intensiven
austausch wie wir also dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz modifizieren
werden da wird ja zum 30.06 und andere
wichtige ausarbeitung der kommission der
von bundesregierung und parlament zur
auswertung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
vorgelegt wenn diese arbeit vorliegt
werden kollege buschmann und ich werden
wir uns einigen auf einen auf die
eckpunkte eines neuen
infektionsschutzgesetzes das werden wir
auch noch vor der sommerpause aller
voraussicht nach werden wir das leisten
können so dass nach der sommerpause bei
der beschluss erfolgen kann aber die
inhalte sollen also noch vor dem sommer
entwickelt werden so dass man auch
klarheit hat was kommt da im herbst an
instrumenten auf uns zu was können wir
dann nutzen was steht uns zur verfügung
ich glaube dass wir da im einvernehmen
einem guten vorschlag machen können
lassen sie mich zum abschluss sagen will
ist jetzt also in gewisser weise
betrüblich dass wir eine sommer welle
haben es ist betrüblich dass der herbst
in gewisser weise nicht so verlaufen
kann wie in vorwahlzeiten aber es gibt
auch licht am ende des tunnels ich
persönlich gehe davon aus ich weiß dass
diese position nicht also
nicht von allen wissenschaftlern gezahlt
aber ich gehe persönlich davon aus dass
es uns gelingen dort in den nächsten
monaten vielleicht schon im nächsten
halben jahr vielleicht im nächsten jahr
auch impfstoffe zu entwickeln mit denen
wir im wesentlichen die ansteckung
verhindern können davon gehe ich
persönlich aus das sind wahrscheinlich
dann auch impfstoffe die über dimoco sei
also beispielsweise als spray impfstoffe
oder also auch in anderer form
appliziert werden können aber wir nähern
uns immer mehr den zustand dass wir auch
impfstoffe adaptierte impfstoffe
entwickeln können die die eigentliche
ansteckung weg bekommen das wird für die
impfstoffe die wir jetzt erwarten können
im september in vollständiger art und
weise noch nicht der fall sein davon
gehe ich aus ist das noch nicht der fall
sein wird aber wir gehen weiter in diese
richtung ich bin selbst also mit diesem
forschungsarbeiten sich sehr gut
vertraut und finde das faszinierend
werden zum schluss diese impfstoffe
haben wenn dann auch eine grunde
immunität in der bevölkerung haben wo
also kohle hat dann eine krankheit ist
wie jede andere infektionskrankheit wir
sind aber jetzt noch nicht da und wir
müssen vermeiden dass wir über viele
wochen hinweg also beispielsweise über
den ganzen herbst und den ganzen winter
100 bis 200 tote pro tag haben das kann
keiner wünschen das muss vermieden
werden da werden wir noch anderen mit
schutzmaßnahmen operieren müssen wir
werden nochmal die impfkampagne nutzen
müssen wir werden diesen sieben punkte
plan den wir jetzt entwickeln auch über
uns dass gesetzgebung entwickeln den
werden wir umsetzen so dass wir sehr gut
durch den also herbst durchkommen werden
und den winter wir werden aber dann
danach in einer situation kommen wo wir
auch dann tatsächlich wieder
zurückkehren zur normalität jetzt würde
ich sagen haben wir es gut im griff aber
noch nicht gelöst und danach werden wir
es auch gelöst haben vielen dank bis
hierhin und wir kommen zu der
einschätzung von herrn verfasser schadet
es ja vielen dank sehr geehrte damen und
herren aktuell steigen die fallzahlen
wieder deutlich lars koch 2 zirkuliert
in der bevölkerung und verbreitet sich
auch weiterhin dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen die sieben tages inzidenz
liegt heute bei 427 das ist etwas
geringer als gestern und dies liegt
vermutlich am gestrigen feiertag in
einigen bevölkerungsreichen
bundesländern wir müssen aber davon
ausgehen dass es auch in der nächsten
zeit weiter steigen wird wo wird
fallzahlen geben wird und dass damit
auch der infektionsdruck auf die
variablen gruppen insbesondere auf die
älteren personen mit grunderkrankungen
und personen pflegeheim weiter steigt
was sind die gründe dafür
zum einen sind immer mehr verpflichtende
maßnahmen aufgehoben worden zum beispiel
dass masken tragen hin räumen dazu
kommen zwei neue omikron varianten oder
sub linien b a 4 und der a 5 der anteil
von b a 5 lag anfang juni bereits bei 24
prozent inzwischen ist er wahrscheinlich
schon die dominierende sub linie und mit
zunehmendem abstand zur letzten impfung
sinkt auch der schutz vor einer erneuten
infektion auch wenn der schutz vor
schwere erkrankung erhalten bleibt die
gute nachricht ist dass es derzeit keine
hinweise darauf gibt das bh 5 zu
schwereren erkrankungen führt als die
anderen nikon supreme ihren bh fünf
verbreitet sich aber noch schneller als
die bisherigen sub linien von omikron
und es handelt sich dabei um eine
sogenannte immun escape variante das
bedeutet dass auch all diejenigen die
schon einmal infiziert waren
die bereits also eine infektion
durchgemacht haben auch mit einer
anderen variante sich weiter oder
nochmals infizieren können die pandemie
ist also in diesem sinne noch nicht
vorbei und das liegt vor allem an den
neuen sub varianten und varianten der
weitere verlauf der pandemie wird aber
nicht nur davon abhängen welche
virusvarianten auftreten sondern ganz
wesentlich auch vom verhalten und von
ihrem status der eltern kommen das gilt
jetzt aber ganz besonders dann auch noch
mal mit blick auf dem herd auf den
herbst
wir sollten uns im alltag seinem alltag
bewusst darüber sein welches risiko wie
er unter den aktuellen umständen
eingehen und eingehen wollen das rk ii
empfiehlt nach wie vor in innenräume mit
mehreren personen zum beispiel im
geschäft im supermarkt oder bei
öffentlichen veranstaltungen
mindestens einen mund nasen schutz zu
tragen das gilt für alle und ganz
besonders für ältere personen und
personen mit grunderkrankungen
veranstaltungsräume sollten außerdem gut
durchlüftet sein es ist wichtig die
hygieneempfehlungen in den alten und
pflegeheim weiterhin sorgfältig
umzusetzen und noch mal zu überprüfen wo
vielleicht noch lücken sind
und bleiben sie bei atemwegs symptomen
zu hause und lassen sie sich testen
impfungen sind weiter wirksam sie
verringern die anzahl der
hospitalisierung und todesfälle deutlich
das gilt besonders dann wenn man eine
auffrischimpfung erhalten hat die dritte
impfung schützt deutlich besser gegen
schwere erkrankung als die zweite
impfung für bestimmte risikogruppen und
menschen über 70 empfiehlt die stiko sie
hatten es gehört auch noch eine zweite
auf beschimpfung also die vierte impfung
und auch ganz wichtig kinder zwischen
fünf und elf jahren sollten nach einer
neuen empfehlung der stiko geimpft
werden in der regel einmal wenn dort
grunderkrankungen vorliegen auch zweimal
ich möchte das noch einmal ganz deutlich
sagen die impfung ist ein wesentlicher
grund dafür dass in der mikrowelle
bislang nicht so viele infizierte ins
krankenhaus mussten oder hat sogar
gestorben sind trotzdem gibt es immer
noch im pflügen etwa 7,5 millionen 18
bis 59 jährigen sind noch ungewiss bei
den über 60 jährigen sind es noch zwei
millionen und auch wenn viele von ihnen
zwischen kurve gehabt haben und ein
gewisses maß an immunität erworben haben
diese reicht allein in der regel nicht
aus um sich gut zu schützen deshalb auch
wenn sie eine oder vielleicht schon
mehrere infektionen durchgemacht haben
lassen sie sich bitte trotzdem impfen
sie bauen dann einen viel besseren
immunschutz aufwarten sie dafür auch
nicht auf einen varianten angepassten
dem stoff vervollständigen sie den im
den begonnen die begonnen den ferien
jetzt einschließlich der empfohlenen
auffrischungsimpfung das ist das beste
was ich mit 19 entgegensetzen können
jetzt im sommer aber vor allen dingen
auch im hinblick auf den herbst vielen
dank vielen dank auch ihre und dann
komme ich zu ihm und starte im saal mit
den kollegen von ihnen aus gesehen
rechts vorne
dann vielleicht die erste frage an herrn
lauterbach was sie zur masten pflicht
sagen sie haben gesagt der siebte punkt
wird noch vorgestellt aber heißt das
dass sie von russland bis oktober oder
anders und von oktober bis ostern eine
maske pflicht in der werbung
wir bereiten derzeit die regeln für den
herbst vor man kann diese regeln auch
quasi zusammenfassen dass das wenn man
so will unsere winterreifen sein werden
also was ich gerade vorgetragen habe die
bitte im innenraum masken zu tragen und
die vierte impfungen empfohlen für
diejenigen selbst schützen wurden oder
andere das sind wenn man so wenig
sommerreifen winterreifen werden
vorbereitet ich spiele einfach um
verständnis dass ich das mit herrn bush
man erst einmal
im hintergrund also dass vorberatung gut
vorbereitet aber es ist klar dass wir so
mehr brauchen als was wir jetzt an
sommerreifen also aufgezogen haben und
davon können sie ableiten was
wahrscheinlich sowohl rauskommt
dann bin ich im saal bei handling
der lauterbach jetzt ganz gerne zu den
impfstoffen nochmal gefragt sie haben
jetzt gesagt dass sie in den nächsten
sechs bis zwölf monaten impfstoffe rat
und die eine ansteckung verhindern
da hätte ich ganz gerne gewusst auf
welcher technologie sieht diese
impfstoffe erwarten und kleiner zusatz
diese impfstoffe die angepasst neben
stoffe die im herbst kommen wie
zuversichtlich sind sie denn dass die
wirklich kommen denn wir haben ja jetzt
schon mehrfach verzögerungen erlebt
rechnen sie fest damit haben sie feste
zusagen dass die im herbst wirklich zur
verfügung stehen
zunächst einmal also gehe ich davon aus
dass wir diese impfstoffe im september
bekommen werden und die also in das so
genannte rowling review das einreichen
die entsprechenden daten hat ja auch
schon begonnen somit also ist das also
mein kenntnisstand dass wir im herbst
wahrscheinlich im september angepasste
impfstoff haben werden die also
impfstoffe die eine infektion
zuverlässig vermeiden also denen das
quasi gelingt das phänomen etwas schade
gerade beschrieben hat das skate film
ihn wieder zu überwinden
diese impfstoffe sind zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht klar absehbar das
ist ich habe eben ja auch gesagt dass
ich das persönlich erwartet dass uns das
gelingen wird dass das aber keine
einvernehmliche position unter
wissenschaftlern ist das wirklich
relativ schwierig weil also es gibt nur
wenige
epitope wo man doch da eben also
sozusagen noch ansetzen kann um das zu
erreichen das wäre dann aber
möglicherweise impfstoffe die sofort in
der schleimhaut werden zum beispiel nach
salem stoffe an diesen impfstoffen wird
gearbeitet und es gibt in der
wissenschaft sozusagen eine gruppe die
glaubt dass es gelingen wird dass man
also immer quasi also antike die lokale
antikörperproduktion so an regeln kann
über die klamotte dass man dort dort
also eine infektion vermeiden kann gibt
aber auch andere die glauben dass es
nicht gelingen somit möchte ich das
einfach ein geschenk auch hier
verstanden wissen das ist nach meiner
einschätzung dass es gelingen wird aber
das wird nicht von jedem so gesehen und
das eine sehr spannende frage da bin ich
auch mit wissenschaftlern der ganzen
welt also in kontakt ich bin selbst kein
ausgewiesener experte impfstoff experte
aber ich verfolge die debatte sehr genau
und hat das privileg mit diesen
beteiligten wissenschaftlern auch
unternehmen im direkten kontakt zu
stehen meine einschätzung ist dass das
gelingen wird aber nicht jetzt habe ich
ganz kurz nachfragen die frage zielt
darauf welcher technologie das basiert
wird das sind das an mrsa impfstoffe
es kann auch zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht sagen es gibt also zb einen
protein basierten impfstoff dem das
quasi zugetraut würde der aber dafür
bisher noch nicht eingesetzt wird man
kann also man kann nicht unbedingt sagen
dass das wieder also herr mehr an
impfstoff für sein werden das könnte
auch durchaus sagen dass mit
kombinationen gearbeitet wird aber das
spielt uns jetzt wirklich tief ins
wissenschaftliche so gras hinein und ich
glaube dass wir das dann vielleicht war
das für das planer besseren gelegenheit
vertiefen sollten aber die schnelle
antwort ist das müssen nicht unbedingt
mrm stoffe sein soll es gibt einen also
protein basierten kandidaten wo ist sehr
plausibel wäre dass er dafür genutzt
werden könnten ich bleibe bei dem thema
impfen und wechsle ins digitale da gibt
es eine ganze reihe an fragen der
kollege des von der rheinischen post
fragt würden sie sich eine erweiterte
stiko empfehlung auf oder eine
erweiterung auf andere
bevölkerungsgruppen wünschen für die
zweite booster impfung die sind ja
dieser bisher für sehr eingeschränkte
bevölkerungsgruppen ausgesprochen diese
empfehlung der stiko hat sich ja noch
einmal zu den derzeitigen
impfempfehlungen geäußert und dem habe
ich nichts hinzuzufügen
ich glaube dass die stiko auch gute
gründe hat so zu empfehlen wie sie
empfiehlt weil sie einfach aus der
perspektive des einzelnen also die
patienten ja eine empfehlung abgeben
muss ich persönlich muss darüber hinaus
natürlich auch noch die public health
sicht also die sicht des öffentlichen
gesundheitswesens im auge haben die
gesamtbevölkerung mit dem auge haben
somit ist das nicht in jedem punkt 100
prozent deckungsgleich dass es aber auch
eine ganz andere perspektive somit habe
ich an die stiko hier keine wünsche die
stiko ist komplett unabhängig macht eine
fantastische arbeit und wird also auch
von mir in der hinsicht respektiert aber
trotzdem ist es so dass viele ärzte also
auch über die stiko empfehlungen aus
kämpfen weil das individuelle arzt
patient verhältnis und mit den einlagen
die man kennen muss natürlich also
mitgedacht werden muss auf das zuletzt
gesagt hat bezieht sich die nachfrage
von herrn drewes er sagt nämlich viele
ärzte halten sich strikt an die stiko
empfehlungen
wie es dann mit diesem widerspruch
umzugehen beziehungsweise woher nehmen
sie vielleicht die annahme das würde ich
jetzt sozusagen ergänzen dass viele
darüber hinaus gehen und trotzdem impfen
also habe ich natürlich mit vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen im direkten
austausch in kontakt und wie sie auch
selbst in dem sinne und es ist einfach
schlicht so dass also die empfehlung
eine empfehlung ist und aber das was der
einzelne patient jetzt wünschen dass der
18 empfiehlt aber wenn das spiel hat
viele andere dinge noch eine rolle
nehmen sie jemanden der zum beispiel
sehr sehr viele kontakte das dann eine
vierte impfung möglicherweise mehr sinn
machen würde als bei jemandem der wenige
kontakte liegt auf der hand oder jemand
der also an besondere risikofaktoren für
die tat uns weiter so mit dass die
individuellen risikofaktoren mit
berücksichtigt werden das ist der erste
schon praxis natürlich geübt
ich würde gerne nochmal dem
themenkomplex impfen bleiben herr linke
war ihre nachfrage dazu auch nie dann
mache ich hier nochmal bei dem kollegen
im chablais weiter genau genau dafür die
nachfrage zu vierten impfung ganz
konkret also jemand er dreimal wm ist
der vielleicht im dezember seine dritte
im programm hat er sich vielleicht sogar
auch noch nicht infiziert hat der sollte
verstehe ich sie richtig jetzt im juni
oder juli durchaus eine 40 impfung mit
den bestehenden beyoncé oder moderner
impfstoff in erwägung ziehen sollte es
in erwägung ziehen
es kommen natürlich auch die faktoren
man muss es einfach immer davon abhängig
machen in welcher situation jetzt jemand
ich bringe ein beispiel wenn jetzt
jemand
gefährdete art der eltern hat die hier
regelmäßig besucht haben aber auch sehr
viele kontakte in dem sinne und kann und
will sich nicht jeden tag texten will
aber sicherstellen dass die eltern die
eltern nicht infiziert oder hat ein
krankes kind und so weiter und so fort
dann sollte man diese dinge mit denken
natürlich mitdenken und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise in einer so
in einer bar arbeiten würde und hätte
also eine gefährdung für longo wird
indem ich zum beispiel eine
autoimmunerkrankung hätte dann würde ich
mich natürlich auch mit der vierten
impfung also ab schützen damit reduziere
ich das risiko zunächst mal für den
sommer wo jetzt die fahrzeuge wieder
steigen dass ich mich infizieren nicht
perfekt aber immerhin und wenn ich mich
infiziere reduziere ich das lockenkopf
mit risiko das risiko stark zu erkranken
da sind ja alles dinge die denkt ja
jemand mit und die denkt auch jeder arzt
mit wenn er jetzt empfiehlt
nachfrage sieht er schade das auch so
also da habe ich nichts hinzuzufügen
emmendorfer rnd kurze nachfrage dazu
nochmal sie hatten eingangs sehr sehr
viel über das thema über 60 gesprochen
also dass sie das die vierte impfung für
für nicht erst für 70 leute sondern 60
schon empfehlen jetzt klang es so als
wenn es auch für 40 50 30 jährige geht
also wie ist das vielleicht noch mal zu
sehen in besonderen konstellationen also
dass ich hatte ihre frage ja so
verstanden als das was wenn das sich
nicht auf die sechzig gruppe beziehen
würde sondern auch jemand der jünger ist
und die impfung um es klar zu sagen ist
ja für alle altersgruppen zugelassen die
wir ja kirchensprecher 0 bei wachsen ich
habe ja nicht über kinderimpfungen
gesprochen sondern die bei erwachsenen
ist für alle erwachsenen zugelassen und
wenn jetzt bei spiels also ein jüngerer
mensch entweder ein risikofaktor für non
profit oder für schwere erkrankungen
oder aber er hat sehr viele kontakte und
wir andere nicht gefährden
dann ist das etwas was jeder ast mit ins
kalkül ziehen würde mit mir angefangen
wenn er die impf empfehlung ausspricht
das ist aber kein gegensatz zur stiko
empfehlung weil die stiko empfehlung
gibt eine empfehlung für den standard
patienten aber ich hatte eben schon
ausgeführt wenn jetzt jemand sehr viele
kontakte und will andere nicht
infizieren ich habe zum beispiel eine
frau die ich hätte eine frau die also
schwer erkrankt und kann die uns
erwartungsvoll dann müssen diese aspekte
ja mit bedacht werden in diese richtung
empfehle ich eben
dann mein immer digital weiter und
bleibe bei
diesen themenkomplex die kollegin
hommels von dow jones fahrt zur vierten
impfung auch ist diese auch empfohlen
wenn man sich nach der zweiten oder
dritten impfung infiziert hat schade sie
sind darauf forschen eingegangen aber
vielleicht spiele ich die frage schafft
und nochmal so konkret an beide weiter
also grundsätzlich kann man die eine
infektion mit zählen bei den jungs
ferien da gibt es eine sehr ausführliche
tabelle bei den stiko empfehlungen in
welcher konstellation das wann der fall
ist aber grundsätzlich kommt es eben
darauf an dass man die entsprechend der
antigen kontakte hat ja also mindestens
drei antigen kontakte für alle sollten
seien also jeder der einmal infiziert
war sollte sich noch mindestens zweimal
impfen und daneben bestimmte gruppen
entsprechend die stiko empfehlungen und
entsprechend der ausführung von herrn
minister eben auch ein viertes mal aber
eine eine infektion kann in dem sinne
als eine impfung zählen muss ein
bisschen schwierig wird wenn man sagt
ich bin jetzt vier mal infiziert gewesen
und muss mich gar nicht mehr impfen
lassen also dieser fall ist in dem sind
nicht abgedeckt aber das würde aber das
will im umkehrschluss bedeuten wenn man
dreimal kämpft ist und einmal infiziert
waren müsste man sich nicht notgedrungen
ein zweites mal impfen lassen also man
sollte sich genau die stiko empfehlungen
angucken da sind die ganzen fälle
durchdekliniert ja und da gibt es ja
verschiedene konstellationen bei vier
impfungen ich persönlich würde nein man
sollte sich also mindestens zweimal
geimpft haben und dann sind entsprechend
auch
infektionen äquivalent zu
haben die stimme genau
hier vorgetragen hat und
diese also frage geht ja auch in die
richtung ist man gut geschützt in dieser
kombination also diese kombination dass
man schon andere infiziert war und sie
hat danach impfen lassen schütz
besonders
so dann bleibe ich noch mal bei diesem
erweiterten themenkomplex der kollege
your dass jordan scottie fragt an sie
gerichtet herr lauterbach arztpraxen
berichten dass ihnen von seiten des bmg
der bisherige vertrag zur ausstellung
von 19 im pfund genesen zertifikaten zum
30.06 gekündigt wird was ist der grund
für diesen schritt und deutet das darauf
hin dass er das bmg ich die pandemie für
beendet betrachtet das glaube ich habe
sich schon beantwortet aber dann also
die pandemie ist nicht beendet und also
muss auch ganz offen sagen dass ich hier
nicht genau war es worauf die frage
abzielt weil die zertifikate können
natürlich weiter also
ausgestellt werden und ich muss das ich
muss das wirklich prüfen aber der mir
ist der umstand nicht einmal bekannt
dann bitte ich den kollegen vielleicht
umgeben fall um eine präzisierung und
bleibe noch mal digital herr denke ich
habe sie auf der liste
der kollege heller fragt wie geht es mit
den impfzentren weiter die ja schon
massiv reduziert wurden wie wie hoch ist
momentan die dunkelziffer gemessen an
den gemeldeten infektionszahlen okay das
mit zwei verschiedene fragen vielleicht
erst im zentrum weil die impfzentren
muss man so betrachten wie eine
berufsfeuerwehr die vorgehalten wird und
also jederzeit einsatzfähig ist wenn der
bedarf da ist und ich glaube dass wir
tatsächlich durch die impfkampagne die
ich eben erwähnt habe das war der erste
der sieben punkte die ich also
vorgetragen habe dass wir durch die
impfkampagne die impfzentren wieder sehr
viel stärker ins spiel bringen werden
dass die berufsfeuerwehr dann wieder
raus muss wenn man so will und
daher also übernimmt der bund auch die
kosten der im zentrum zur hälfte bis zu
100 millionen euro pro monat und wir
werden die eben auch also im herbst
wieder benötigen und die zweite frage
dunkel zu fahren bietet also wie hoch
ist die dunkelziffer gemessen an den
gemeldeten infektionen na da haben wir
nach wie vor keine wirklich so
belastbare informationsort sehr schwer
zu sagen
ich gehe selbst von einer dunkelziffer
aus von mindestens 100 prozent so dass
wir also doppelt so viele pferde
tatsächlich haben wir derzeit
registrieren das ist der wert mit dem
also das robert-koch-institut auch also
mathematisch ist dass man sich sehr gut
also abgeleitet in der vergangenheit
auch operiert hat und also ich habe dem
nichts hinzuzufügen aber wir haben
tatsächlich keine präzisere daten weil
wir an der entsprechende panel
untersuchungen nicht durchgeführt haben
der vergangenheit ansieht
ja also wir können es natürlich einmal
sind haben wir erfahrungen aus der
vergangenheit als man im grunde noch
vergleichen konnte anhand der antikörper
bestimmung im blut wer hat sich wie
viele haben sich infiziert und wie sind
praktisch zeitgleich im meldesystem
gelandet da hatten wir am anfang eine
starke und erfassung bis zum faktor 6 in
den ersten in den ersten in der ersten
welle und dann hat sich das so um die
zwei eingependelt und eine andere
methode mit der wir das zur zeit auch
noch abschätzen können ist praktisch die
die genetische variante der isolate die
man findet sie verändern sich praktisch
immer mit einer infektion und je mehr
infektionen desto mehr veränderung das
kann man dann mathematisch zurückrechnen
da kommt man dann etwa auf denselben
wert also es einen erfahrungswert was
anderes ein wert aus dieser aus der
diversität der der viren abgeleitet und
das ist in etwa größen deckungsgleich
der kollege weg nach von der dpa fragt
noch erwarten sie klare frühzeitige
angaben für die bevölkerung wer genau
welchen impfstoff impfstoffen nutzen
soll bisher sind die stiko empfehlungen
oft später als das tatsächlich im
geschehen und werden auch nicht
allgemein zugänglich verkündet
wir werden auf jeden fall sehr
transparent mit den unterschiedlichen
impfstoffen die wir zur verfügung haben
umgehen hat ja schon gesagt dass wir
hier reden dann vorgehen drei
unterschiedliche impfstoffe linien
kouhan bei und economy com
erwarten wir moderner
bivalent erwarten wir dass werden
wahrscheinlich die drei impfstoff linien
seien denen wir arbeiten
sie werden sich in bezug auf die
wirksamkeit bei b a 5 und b a 4
unterscheiden davon gehe ich aus und
diese unterschiede werden wir
transparent machen die aber dann kann
jeder einzelne sich auf der grundlage
dieser unterschiede entscheiden aber was
wir gemacht haben also ist dass wir uns
so viel impfstoff geschafft dass wir
jedem jeden impfstoff anbieten können
das bedeutet wir werden auch dann
impfstoff verwerfen müssen das klar weil
die impfstoffe die vielleicht nicht so
stark sind die werden dann nicht also
verlangt werden die werden wir dann
entsprechend vernichten müssen aber die
alternative wäre gewesen dass wir nur
ein oder zwei impfstoffe beschafft
hätten dann hätten wir aber das risiko
da gewesen dass der impfstoff also den
wir nicht geschafft hat vielleicht der
beste gewesen wäre und das wollten wir
nicht daher ist es hier an der
redundante beschaffung die unterschiede
werden transparent gemacht wir beten
aber jedem jeden impfstoff an aber es
wird keine speziellen empfehlungen
bestimmte impfstoffe für gestalteten
vergangen das kann man nicht machen weil
also das also ist das ist
das ist nicht wirklich angemessen es
muss also bei den impfstoffen auch
berücksichtigt werden dass
unterschiedliche nebenwirkungsprofil wie
gute image noch vor untersucht sind wie
gut jenige den impfstoff in der
vergangenheit vertragen hat und so
weiter da kommen viele individuelle
aspekte hinein da lassen sich also ganz
grundsätzliche empfehlungen für einen
spezifischen impfstoffs oder hersteller
nicht abwarten dann weckte ich ihnen
sagen war ein trinker und dann bei der
kollegin oder bei ihnen auf genau
lauterbach ich werde ganz gerne mal auf
das bild mit den sommerreifen
zurückgekommen wenn wir jetzt
feststellen dass es im sommer dauernd
schneit also sprich sommer welle anstieg
der infektionen dann frage ich mich
warum die maßnahmen erst im herbst
kommen wenn sie doch selber darauf
hinweisen dass zumindestens was longo
beat angeht wir eine bedenkliche
entwicklung haben also deswegen die
frage kommen oder schließen sie aus dass
weitere beschränkungen jetzt schon
kommen müssen also wir haben im letzten
jahr und dem vorletzten jahr
reisebeschränkungen zb durch diskutiert
wir haben beschränkungen für festivals
durchdiskutiert die im moment auch
wieder als ein faktor gelten warum die
zahlen vielleicht in die höhe gehen
schließen sie aus dass vor den
veränderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes nach der
sommerpause jetzt schon weitere
maßnahmen beschlossen werden müssen sie
sind jetzt nicht geplant weil jeder
einzelne sich jetzt relativ gut schützen
kann also bei den fallzahlen die wir
jetzt in der sonne situation erwarten
ist der schutz des einzelnen also
organisierbar zum einen also man kann
sich relativ gut draußen aufhalten wenn
man also und wenn man in den innenräumen
ist kann man mass getragen und wenn
einem das nicht also sicher genug ist
dann kann man sich darüber hinaus auch
noch impfen lassen somit also sind die
sommerreifen also für die lage in der
wir derzeit sind ausreichend den schutz
wenn man sich selbst geben kann reicht
aus
ok dann bin ich bei der kollegin von
ihnen aus gewinnen
ich hätte noch meine nachfrage zu den
herzen können sie ein bisschen direkt
ans mikro sprechen das ganze besser hört
danke
ich hatte noch nachfragern herrn
lauterbach was die maßnahmen für den
herbst an geht sie hatten gesagt in den
pflegeeinrichtungen soll es eine
zuständige person geben die hygiene
konzept erarbeitet und auch kontrolliert
und auch wie der impfstatus der
bewohnerinnen ist
wird es dazu bestimmte hilfen gehen bei
jetzt sind ja auch schon
pflegeeinrichtungen personalmangel wie
soll das organisiert werden oder sind
die pflegeeinrichtungen selbst
verantwortlich die details werden wir
noch aus erwarten dazu wird es also
einen
gesetzesentwurf in kürze geben
und im rahmen also diese gesetzlichen
regelung wird auch klar gestellt werden
in welcher art und weise wie die
pflegeeinrichtungen dort unterstützen
können aber wir wollen es tatsächlich
anders als in der vergangenheit nicht
also
dem zufall überlassen ob einzelne
einrichtungen oder träger also die
bewohner gut schützen oder nicht ganz so
gut schützen es gab ja auch sehr große
unterschiede in bezug auf die frage wie
viele menschen haben sich infiziert wir
haben jetzt wirklich ganz tolle
instrumente zur verfügung wo wir die
menschen in pflege einer schönen
schützen können und das muss eine
priorität sein und da muss die
zuständigkeit ganz klar definiert sein
auch als person haben also relativ zu
zahlen wer ist zuständig für die gilde
konzepte wie er sorgt dafür dass die
impflücken geschlossen werden wer sorgt
dafür dass im erkrankungsfall
tatsächlich die arzneimittel noch
genommen werden genutzt werden die die
schweren verläufe verhindern können das
muss ganz klar sein
denn der kollege fahren sie müssen wir
noch mal mit ihrem namen weiter helfen
sorry ich muss ihn eigentlich wissen
alles gut tobias lauf vom deutschen
ärzteblatt
lauterbach sie hatten vor ein paar
wochen
angekündigt dass ich die vergleichsweise
ruhig inspektions lage im sommer nutzen
wollen unter anderem wird das politische
baustellen anzugehen
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen anders
wenn der sommer werden hat sich da jetzt
da stand ein wenig geändert gibt es
etwas neues oder kommen gibt es
verzögerungen stichworte wie epa
krankenhäuser form des abo
finanzen.net ski-star aktuelle stand
das ist nichts anderes als wir arbeiten
derzeit also an einem gesetzentwurf
an eckpunkten zur fairen vorschlag und
gesundheits kiosk und community has
wir arbeiten an einem pflege
entlastungsgesetz wo es also darum geht
über
personalbemessung die instrumente in der
pflege und die daten die wir haben aus
den aus der also pflege abrechnung im
selbst kostendeckungsprinzip die
überlassung von assen abteilungen
festhalten wir arbeiten sehr intensiv an
einem umfänglichen finanz
stabilisierungs gesetzes bin ich seit
wochen mit finanzminister lindner im
austausch wir arbeiten im expertenrat
krankenhaus an einem entwurf wie also
die
vergütung für kinderkliniken für
geburtshilfe kliniken organisiert werden
soll auch die notfall die
notfallversorgung neu organisiert werden
soll also um nur ein paar beispiele zu
nennen dort wird der vorschlag der
expertenkommission in den nächsten 14
tagen vorliegen danach wird das angehört
durch die verbände und dann wird es eine
kommission auch geben vielleicht noch
vor der sommerpause vielleicht danach
von gesundheitsministerium fraktionen
und ländern also auch daran wird sehr
intensiv gearbeitet
somit wir sind an all diesen gesetzen in
arbeit die sie gerade angesprochen hatte
dann wechsle ich noch mal ins digitale
da geht noch mal um die gkv finanzierung
auch dann nehme ich jetzt mal zwei
fragen zusammen von der kollegin
mißlbeck vom rc nachrichtendienst und
von der kollegin slavik von der
süddeutschen zeitung
nicht nur unionsabgeordnete sondern auch
regierungspolitiker
fordern inzwischen das dringend andere
gesetzesvorhaben angegangen werden allen
voran die gkv finanzierungen hier
nochmal die frage wie sie derzeit fahren
für dieses und weitere bringen bevor
gesetzesvorhaben aber so konkret nach
dem zeitplan gefragt wann das waren mit
einem entwurf zu rechnen und in eine
ganz ähnliche richtung fragt auch die
kollegin slawik wie weit
sind die finanzierungspläne
fortgeschritten
da wird das so seit wochen sehr intensiv
verhandelt der bundesfinanzminister ist
derzeit natürlich sehr gefordert weil er
also die
finanzierungslücken in ganz
verschiedenen bereichen abdecken muss
man bedingt durch die ukraine krise dann
zum zweiten also die inflations
belastungen die jetzt kommen
energiekosten und zweiter und somit
verhandeln wir dort also es waren heute
zum beispiel wieder verhandlungen also
vorgesehen die mussten kurzfristig
verschoben werden weil
bundesfinanzminister der termin nicht
gebunden war wir verhandeln aber sehr
regelmäßig möchte ich sagen und sobald
wir da zu einem ergebnis gekommen sind
werde ich das der öffentlichkeit nicht
vorenthalten das ist ganz klar wir sind
zeitlich nicht im druck weil wir werden
tatsächlich also noch vor dem vor dem
sommer mit dem entwurf im kabinettssaal
und werden also dem zahl frauen nutzen
aber ich bin einfach um verständnis das
ist kein gesetz was ich vorlegen kann
ohne dass es zu einer einigung mit dem
bundesfinanzminister mit auch mit den
haushältern gekommen ist und daher also
kann ich berichten dass wir dann sehr
intensiv arbeiten schon lange aber ich
kann es erst nach einer einigung vorher
kann ich es nicht vorlegen und
zwischenstände über den verlauf der
gespräche möchte ich einfach nicht
preisgeben darum bitte ich dass das
bitte ich mir nach zu sehen wenn sie uns
natürlich sehr interessieren würden die
zwischenstände die kollegin projekte von
angefragt und srk gerichtet was ist
anders geworden mit den kindern macht
das rkw jetzt diese generalisierte
empfehlung für die impfung ist die quote
der kinder die schwer krank werden
größer durch omikron bzw
hat die sich verändert also zunächst mal
nicht das lka die empfehlungen die
empfehlung macht die ständige
impfkommission dass es ein unabhängiges
gremium von experten das vom bmg berufen
wird und so regiert wie die
geschäftsstelle haben also wir
unterstützen die mit datenaufbereitung
und machen die redaktion im grunde der
empfehlung aber die empfehlung kommt
eben von der stiko das ist denke ich ein
wichtiger punkt und der andere punkt ist
die stiko hat sich eben auch noch mal
und das tut sie ja eigentlich immer auch
bei allen anderen empfehlungen schaut
sich die daten insgesamt regelmäßig neu
an und was die stiko im wesentlichen ja
tut ist die abwägung zwischen
potenzielle gefährdung also ein risiko
durch die infektion und einem minimalen
rest risiko durch durch die durch die
impfung das ist ja auch in bestimmten
fällen immer gibt und die stiko geben im
herbst noch der auffassung dass die
gerade was die daten über die risiken
der impfung angeht einfach noch nicht
ausreichend daten vorlagen um
letztendlich diese generelle empfehlung
zu machen und hat deshalb die empfehlung
in zentriert auf die personengruppe bei
den kindern die ein besonders hohes
risiko hatte also die kinder mit grund
empfehle erkrankungen inzwischen gibt es
mehr daten die zeigen eben dass die
impfung für kinder sehr sicher ist und
es gibt natürlich auch noch mehr daten
die zeigen dass es eben auch bei kindern
quantitativ ist das jetzt nicht
irgendwie mehr geworden aber sie zeigen
eben auch dass kinder auch schwer
erkranken können da gibt es so genannte
pimps und es gibt im juca die tis und
andere erkrankungen und es wird eben
regelmäßig neu bewertet und mit der
neuen datengrundlage ist die stiko eben
zu der auffassung gekommen dass auch
unter dieser abwägung alle kinder nicht
nur die kinder mit besonderen risiken
von der impfung profitieren
schränkt das insofern jetzt ein dass sie
sagen zunächst einmal eine impfung
sicherlich auch ein bisschen mit dem
gedanken dass sehr viele kinder auch
schon früher einmal infiziert waren und
schon ein antigen kontakt haben und
sicherlich auch mit der idee
das wenn jetzt eine sehr starke welle
kommt oder auch noch mal andere
virusvarianten dann schon eine impfung
praktisch gegeben ist und man dann noch
einen schnitt an der zweiten impfung
dass auch gegebenenfalls komplettieren
könnte wenn die situation sich noch mal
ändern
es kommt digital noch eine frage auf die
vorhaben rande thema war hat nach ihren
erkenntnissen der ansturm auf das neue
euro ticket zu einem anstieg der
infektionszahlen beigetragen genau das
kann ich nicht sagen die entsprechenden
daten sehen wir nicht vor
dann können
wir haben ja also zu recht die also
masken pflicht im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
weitergeführt das war ja auch umstritten
aber ich habe es immer für richtig
gehalten und da hat sich meine position
nicht verändert ich glaube dass dies auf
jeden fall geholfen haben dürfte
schlimmeres zu verhindern
damit bin ich dazu
dann bin ich erst mal hin trinken und
dann bei ihnen
ja schade ich habe eine frage zu der
datenlage lauterbach ac a d das waren
klare übersicht haben möchte über die
belegten betten und freien betten den
initiativ stationen der expertenrat
fordert mehr ganz so viel breiteren
besseren übersicht gleichzeitig sind ja
ihre daten die sie melden soll ich sagen
lückenhafte als noch vor einem jahr
zumindest was die neuinfektionen angeht
an bestimmten tagen wird gar nicht
gemeldet viele bundesländer melden nicht
mehr an wochenenden oder feiertagen wie
gestern und sie selber darauf
hingewiesen deswegen hätte ich ganz
gerne noch mal bewusst wie sieht die
datenlage im moment beurteilen
angesichts der sommer meldet jetzt kommt
und vielleicht können sie auch was sagen
zum digitalisierung stand der
gesundheitsämter denn das galt ja als
voraussetzung dass man vielleicht doch
einfacher melden kann
ja also
der datenlage ich bin da eigentlich
teile den allgemeinen optimismus dass
wir im blindflug sind oder ähnliches
blind oder den pessimismus dem den teil
ich nicht wo sich sagen wir haben für
alle wesentlichen fragestellungen bis
auch die in lücke die jetzt geschlossen
wird was letztendlich die übersicht über
die bettenbelegung 1 haben wir gute
daten man muss diese daten aber eben
auch entsprechend interpretieren und in
den kontext stellen die meldedaten die
erfüllen im wesentlichen zwei dinge und
kein meldesystem das letztendlich darauf
aufgebaut ist das ist letztendlich
routinediagnostik in der
krankenversorgung einsammelt wenn ich
das so sagen darf das ist vollständig
jedes meldesystem das so vorgeht hat
eben entsprechend eine untererfassung
die sich aus verschiedenen schritten
ergibt zum beispiel schon allein weil
nicht jeder zum arzt gibt aber das was
das meldesystem leisten soll das leistet
eben das erste ist ausbrüche erkennen
das ist praktisch auf der lokalen ebene
wird über die das meldesystem der
ausbruch gemeldet und wenn wir jetzt
regionalen oder auch 100 in der
bundesweite betrachten dann ist der
zweite punkt der eben hier gemessen
werden kann die dynamik der transmission
gehen die fallzahlen runtergehen die
fallzahlen hoch da kommt es jetzt nicht
so sehr darauf an ob es tatsächlich 600
die inzidenz ist oder oder 495 es kommt
auf den trend an es ist ganz
entscheidend
daneben haben wir aber auch noch andere
systeme die letztendlich helfen und zwar
test unabhängig helfen diesen überblick
zu bewahren das ist die syndrome
schüssel williams mit der symbolischen
service nehmen wir eine stichprobe von
atemwegsinfektionen der bevölkerung und
zwar auf drei ebenen einmal auf der
ebene von der allgemeinbevölkerung die
noch nicht zum arzt geht in arztpraxen
und auch in krankenhäusern
alle personen werden dort angeguckt auf
stichproben ebene die eine akute
atemwegsinfektion haben und dann wird
geguckt welches virus haben die denn da
guckt also von der anderen richtung und
dadurch kann man eben diese zahlen auch
noch mal in der in der wertigkeit das
ist dann vollständig im sinne einer
stichprobe die man hochrechnen kann
unabhängig von von test regime und test
schemata die man zurzeit anwendet und
mit diesen daten kann man natürlich dann
einmal sehen wie schwer ist das wo
befinden sich die meisten patienten
zurzeit im krankenhaus in der arztpraxis
oder suchen sie gar keinen arzt aus und
man hat eben auch noch mal eine instanz
die man daraus berechnet kann wir tun
das auch im täglichen lagebericht mich
in form einer inzidenz aber wir sagen
das entspricht soundsoviel infektionen
in dieser woche auf bevölkerungs ebene
und was man damit eben auch tun kann
wenn man sich das krankenhaus anschaut
man kann eben auch vergleichen es ist
immer die frage mit oder ankur wittmann
kann vergleichen die insolvenzen aus dem
meldesystem die im krankenhaus gemeldet
werden also was vitalisierung aus dem
meldesystem mit hochgerechneten fällen
die mit einer akuten atemwegsinfektion
im krankenhaus liegen die erste frage
ist ja wer nicht im krankenhaus und hat
einen positiven test auf kur wird das
sind auch personen die sich infiziert
haben nur mild erkrankt sind aber sich
zum beispiel das bein gebrochen haben
und wer nicht im krankenhaus mit einer
akuten atemwegsinfektion und hat von
denen dann cupid und diese zahlen kann
man übereinander legen das können sie im
wochenbericht auch anschauen können wir
seit anfang der kogit pandemie die
zahlen vergleichen und da sehen wir eben
dass das relativ deckungsgleich war in
den ersten wellen jetzt in der letzten
omikron werde aber nicht dass es da
besonders bei den jüngeren altersgruppen
auch sehr viele fälle im krankenhaus gab
die letztendlich
nicht wegen einer atemwegsinfektion da
waren sondern das war sozusagen eine
neben diagnose und zum belastung im
gesundheitswesen hatte haben wir dass
die wir ist damit dem wir eben mit dem
fokus auf intensivstationen sehen können
wie stark ist die belastung und was wir
da eben noch verbessern wollen ist das
muss man noch mit der hand eingeben es
wird in zukunft eben auch dann
elektronisch geschehen und damit dann
etwas schneller und und medienbruchfrei
also diesen dingern diesem system die
ich gerade vorgestellt haben noch mal
kurz umrissen habe kann man die
wesentlichen fragen
ausbruch transmission dynamik schwere
der infektion belastung des
gesundheitswesens in der engpass
ressource
intensivstation zurzeit nur da später
auch später woanders auf der
normalstation kann man das sehr gut
beurteilen und monitoren
das heißt um es richtig zu verstehen
weil wir täglich diese zahlen melden die
infektionszahlen sie sind eigentlich
relativ entspannt angesichts dieser
meldung nötig kite von gesundheitsämtern
und ländern
ja es ist ja nicht so dass sie dass die
zahlen jetzt endlich weg sind die am
wochenende nicht gemeldet werden die
werden dann eben in der nächsten woche
nach gewählt
die frage die sich hier stellt ist es
tatsächlich sinnvoll tagesaktuell sich
diese zahlen anzugucken weil es gibt
eben ein melde verzug es gibt dadurch
dass gesundheitsämter und ärzte am
wochenende nicht in dem umfang tätig
sind gibt es eben diese beulen in der in
der kurve die sehen wir ja seit anfang
an und man könnte jetzt endlich auch
wenn nicht der anspruch erhoben werden
würde wir wollen dass täglich sehen man
könnte das auch in etwas grösseren
intervallen machen dann werden diese
fälle ja alle drin und man hätte nicht
an von einem tag auf den anderen die
unsicherheit also man könnte das auch
wöchentlich berichten im moment ist der
bedarf ja von allen seiten so dass von
der politik und auch von der
öffentlichkeit und der presse dass wir
es im moment noch für besser halten das
eben täglich zu berichten und dann zu
erläutern
ja vielleicht anschlussfrage als fazit
ich kann mich erinnern vor einigen
jahren war schon mal hier gesessen das
lka bewahrt und dann hat man sich diese
pressekonferenz im herbst und im winter
noch mal angeschaut und darf auch mal
dass er hat ja damals schon gewarnt aber
ehrlich gesagt war noch gar nicht so
viele von uns hier selbst kritisch kann
man jetzt vielleicht mal sagen haben wir
ein déjà vu werden wir im dezember 2022
uns diese pk wieder angucken und sagen
sie haben alles gesagt zwei millionen
über 60 sind nicht geimpft die schulen
haben immer noch keine luftfilter und
fuchs das ist im prinzip das gleiche wie
werden anders dastehen schon auf
grundlage von drei faktoren die sicher
sind also es werden sehr viel mehr leute
geimpft sein war jetzt schon mehr geben
sind werden sehr viel mehr leute schon
infiziert gewesen sein dass es eben
ausgeführt die daher besseren schutz
haben und darüber hinaus er wird es auch
so sein dass wir mit einer variante zu
bringen haben woraus sich bab a5 oder
eine ähnliche variante die nicht so
schwer verlauf das also ich stehe auf
jeden fall besser da das ist wird nicht
vergleichbar sein das muss man klar
sagen das kann man jetzt schon sehen und
zum zweiten also diese sieben punkte von
denen sechs jetzt vorbereitet werden
noch bevor überhaupt das
infektionsschutzgesetz angepasst wird
das sind dinge die wir jetzt schon
vorbereiten somit also gehe ich davon
aus dass sehr viel davon stehen wird und
zum schluss ist es so wenn man jetzt
sagt okay wenn die impfkampagne nicht so
erfolgreich sein wird das kann also an
uns liefen dass wir sie nicht gut
gemacht haben das glaube ich aber nicht
wir werden kämpfen es kann aber auch
daran liegen dass die bevölkerung
einfach die impfung nicht möchte das ist
auch eine autonome entscheidung wir
müssen das kann man nicht dass eine
niederlage der politik unbedingt
abbuchen wenn die bevölkerung also eine
gute impfung nicht will auch wenn wir
sie tatsächlich
versuchen zu vermitteln
antalya bevölkerung ist steht im risiko
will sich aber nicht nutzen dann ist das
nicht automatisch an verlag versagen der
politik das wäre ein versagen der
politik wenn wir beispielsweise im
herbst stünden und es gäbe also
international einen guten im stoff den
wir aber nicht geschafft hätten das
wären versagen der politik wenn ich
beispielsweise hier vertreten musste und
die frage kommen ja haben sie den sohn
so impfstoff und wir sagen dann dafür
habe kein vertrag das wäre ein problem
oder wenn wir also
auskunft gegeben hätten werden wir die
iba fünf fälle die jetzt kommt
verharmlost hätten indem ich
beispielsweise das was wir jetzt sehen
hier begrüßt hätte wenn ich sagte du
hast ein segen dass wir hier zu diesen
welle haben ich habe wenn wir jetzt die
bade stünden und würden und begrüßen
dass die sommer welle kommen und so
weiter und so fort dass wir ein problem
der politik aber das wird so nicht
stattfinden
daher bin ich sicher dass wir im herbst
besser dastehen als in der vergangenheit
eine letzte frage eine ganz kurze letzte
frage
damit wir die zeit nicht zu sehr
überreizen heraus genau vielen dank ich
weiß noch wie ich kurz zu machen es geht
eigentlich selbe stoßrichtung der
unterschied zu den vorherigen
herbst/winter der stör hat der jetzt
kürzlich darauf hingewiesen dass die
krankenhaus incidents ja weitergehen
weiterhin fallen würde und sieht das
ganze problem nicht so scharf was wird
sich denn dann gehen denn das ist
erstmal teilen sie die ansicht von herrn
stört was die aktuelle situation schlage
da an geht und zweitens welche
unterschiede wird das beispielsweise
ausmachen ebenso im vergleich zum
beispiel zum letzten winter
wir haben ja in den ländern wo die b 5
variante also
schon also etwas länger beobachtet wird
haben wir ja gesehen dass die
krankenhaus also anpassung gestiegen
sind beispielsweise jetzt stärkt es in
england braucht wieder stärker an dass
sie sind portugal geschehen in portugal
sind auch die sterblichkeit gestiegen
und das andere varianten
ich hatte es ja auch korrekt ausgeführt
hatte dass eine variante die genauso
schwer lauf wie baa2 oder vielleicht
sogar etwas aggressiver verläuft dass
die dann auch die gleichen sterbezahlen
wieder mitbringt wenn die also incident
stark dass es hier liegt auf der hand
alles andere also würde schlicht
epidemiologisch überhaupt keinen sinn
machen danach kann sind das eine
variante die genauso schwer verläuft
wenn ich dann mehr davon habe deutlich
mehr davon habe nicht dazu führen würde
dass zuerst die kranken aussagen wieder
starten dann nicht mehr bezahlen und das
beobachten wir ja auch in den ländern wo
das der fall ist somit ist das also
nicht realistisch
also
es ist aus meiner sicht also sehr
wichtig dass man eines daher ist die
frage wichtig eines muss man auch mal
klar sagen nun einen ganz klaren
unterschied ob ich jetzt mal nicht wegen
dich auf den herbst vorbereitet indem
ich die infektion riskiere oder indem
ich mich impfen lasse es gibt ja auch
leute die überlegen sich jetzt lasse ich
doch jetzt im sommer die infektion
passieren bin ich also für den otto
winter gut vorbereitet dass davon ist
strikt abzuraten aus drei gründen der
erste grund ist der wenn ich mich selbst
in ihre stadt dass ich mich impfen lasse
infiziere ich auch andere das heißt
meine entscheidung habe auch
konsequenzen für andere die
möglicherweise durch meinen fehler zu
tode kommen das ist keine kleinigkeit
also sie so zu denken blendet aus dass
man eine infektion wenn ich mich impfen
lasse stecke ich keinen anderen wenn ich
mich aber freiwillig infiziere dann also
ich denke ich an dran das ist ein großer
unterschied zweiter punkt wenn ich mich
infiziert habe ich ein nicht
unerhebliches longo fit risiko auch
bionicon das gleich durch die impfungen
etwas sinken aber die da wachsen die
bäume nicht in den himmel und viele
kämpfen hatten lange und der dritte
punkt ist viele haben risikofaktoren die
sie gar nicht kennen sind sehr viele
leute also unterwegs wahrscheinlich
sogar hier im raum die ihre eigentlichen
risikofaktor gar nicht kennen es gibt
zum beispiel viele
immundefekte gg a mangel beispielsweise
eg man also immundefekte die also im
alltag da so gar nicht also bekannt sind
die sich aber auswirken und somit geht
jeder dann auch dort ins netz eco somit
also die freiwillige infektionen oder
die sagen mal unvorsichtige infektionen
im sommer ist keine verheißung sondern
ist immer ein risiko für einen selbst
oder für dritte da ist die zusätzliche
impfung immer verbessern wie immer das
kolleg
ergänzen dürfte also man ist es ja ich
jedes mal so bei jeder welle so gewesen
dass die welle beginnt in den jungen und
mittleren altersgruppen das sind die
aktiven leute die letztendlich zu den
veranstaltungen gehen und so weiter und
so fort und das ist auch diesmal so dass
ich mal an unserer heatmap im
wochenbericht dieser dieser dunkle
färbung beginnt immer bei den jungen und
mittleren altersgruppen und dann pflanzt
sie sich in der gesellschaft fort zu den
älteren altersgruppen das sind dann die
die schwer erkranken und das sind dann
die die auch ins krankenhaus kommen und
auch auf der intensivstation landen das
dauert immer einige zeit erst steigen
die fallzahlen
gerade wenn die neue welle kommt jünger
altersgruppen sind betroffen dann
breitet sich das aus hin zu den
risikogruppen und dann sehen wir die
zunehmende bedingung in den
krankenhäusern die wir im übrigen aber
jetzt auch da ist immer der blick in die
berichte des lka nicht schlecht auch für
herrn stören dass auch ihr seit etwa
einer woche die hospitalisierung sinti
tänzen bereits wieder steigen also
dieser punkt ist schon jetzt endlich
überschritten und es geht wieder in die
gegenteilige richtung gleichwohl und das
hatten wir ja auch gesagt durch die
impfungen und durch die omikron variante
ist natürlich das verhältnis zwischen f
infektionen und hospitalisierung und
schweren krankheitsverläufen jetzt
anders als es früher der fall war in den
vergangenen jahren aber das verhältnis
natürlich nicht aufgehoben je mehr fälle
es gibt desto mehr schwer schwere fälle
werden auch dazu kommen insbesondere
dann auch bei den älteren und personen
mit grunderkrankungen also den risiko
wir hoffen auf kein déjà vu im herbst
unter hoffen trotzdem dass wir sie hier
mal wieder begrüßen dürfen in diesem
sinne einen guten wochenausklang und
einen schönen tag noch